this Fast Tax Market return to form for
the fast Saga or is it way too Over the
Top early reviews are in so gather your
found family and check out what the
critics are saying as the end of the
road officially Begins the Fast and
Furious franchise has evolved from a
slightly over-the-top series about
street racing and organized crime to a
spectacle of vehicular destruction
skyscraper stunts and even a trip to
outer space in a rocket-powered Pontiac
Fiero Tom Toretto stomped so hard he
brought down a crumbling parking garage
Lou Cobbs redirected an ice skating
torpedo with his arms the action is
absurd and that's the appeal that was
awesome of course this Legacy of
uninhibited Ridiculousness means that
fastx has some Almighty expectations to
live up to the good news though is that
the franchise hasn't run out of gas and
the action department just yet early
reports indicate that the latest sequel
is non-stop Carnage with critic and
podcast host Nathan Flynn posting on
Twitter past X is a fun time in the
movies delivering all the high octane
action Global spectacle and grumbled Vin
Diesel monologues about family you come
to expect from this franchise that said
Bonkers action is meaningless unless
there's a central conflict with between
Dom's ragtag group of Heroes and a
formidable villain Jason momoa's Dante
has been tasked with bringing The
Inferno and fastx and early reactions
have heaped Praise on the actor's
performance I'm Dante I'm Shantae Mamoa
reportedly relishes his villainous role
in fast acts the actor believes that he
got stuck playing Goody Two-Shoes
characters for far too long so he told
variety that he welcomes the opportunity
to portray a compelling bad guy in a
high-profile project his fashion shows
on the screen and fans of praised
Dante's wickedness on social media
critic and podcaster Matt rohrbeck
tweeted Jason Momoa is the exact amount
of unhinged needed in the latest chapter
of this live action Saturday morning
cartoon soap opera I live laugh love the
melodrama some viewers think memo as a
highlight of the entire movie critic and
journalist Scott Menzel wrote Jason
Momoa steals the show over and over
again writer and critic kit Stone added
fast X is the best ride you'll take this
year Jason momoa's peacock-ish villainy
steals the show don't expect Dante to be
a sympathetic villain either several
early viewers compared the character to
the Joker due to his unhinged
personality such as Cinema Blends Eric
Eisenberg who posted momoa's Dante is a
gleeful psychopath and it's delightful
glowing early reviews aside The Fast and
Furious franchise isn't for everyone
some people can't look past the
unrealistic action set pieces so fast X
probably won't be met with universal
Acclaim film critic Emmanuel noaz Ed
found some scenes too over the top to
comprehend writing fast axes on cruise
control with ridiculous stunts and logic
defy in action however the reviewer did
at least reserve some praise from amoa's
villainous performance noting that the
actor quote was the Saving Grace as an
entertaining villain on the flip side
some viewers had a blast with a gunko
action sequences 615 film critic Kevin
Allen believes that fast X is the best
franchise installment since Furious 7.
simply due to the absurdity of the
action scenes and the performances of
Momoa and Brie Larson Additionally the
reviewer took a moment to praise the
filmmakers saying that director Louis
letterier maximizes the stakes with
solid Direction elsewhere some early
viewers appreciated the self-aware
nature of the film and praised it for
not taking itself too seriously meaning
that it's everything people expect at
this point from a fast and Furious yarn
[Music]